RETO MEIER: Today I
learned that when you're
visiting the city
by the bay, you
may want to avoid spending too
much time in the Tenderloin.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer advocate.
Join me today as I investigate
the San Francisco Police
Department incidents
public data set
to discover how crime is
distributed around the city
without the danger of having
to go outside with BigQuery.
If you create a heat
map like this one,
showing the density
of SFPD incidents
in San Francisco since 2010,
the Tenderloin district
really stands out as a place
we probably want to avoid.
We can investigate
further by querying
for areas with a
high concentration
of a particular crime.
By calculating the standard
deviation of both the latitude
and longitude for
each type of crime,
we can find which
crimes have the greatest
concentration in a particular
area and where those areas are.
From this table, we
can see that drug crime
is the most concentrated.
In total, 75% of the
drug-related crimes
in the categories from
the previous table
occurred in this part
of San Francisco.
The red boundary here indicates
the Tenderloin district.
We also learned that
prostitution arrests
are highly concentrated.
In this case, they're
split between two
separate but distinct areas.
Now by going in reverse, we
get this table showing us
the most highly
distributed crimes--
crimes that occur with similar
frequencies all over the city.
Notice that burglary,
theft, and found property
make up 7 of the top 10.
This map shows locations
with at least one burglary
or attempted break-in.
In terms of
residential break-ins,
74% are the only
break-in recorded
at that particular location.
This map shows only locations
with five or more burglary
break-ins.
In terms of personal
safety, it's
the areas where there's lots
of tourists and shoppers
where you're most likely to get
mugged or pick-pocketed while
in the city as shown
in this heat map.
BigQuery includes
many more public data
sets for San Francisco
as well as other cities,
including New York and Chicago.
What can you discover about
the cities we live in?
With BigQuery,
your first terabyte
of processing and 10 gigabytes
of storage each month is free.
Go to BigQuery today, and
create your own San Francisco
and crime statistic
visualizations,
and share them with us.
And of course,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.